why do you think more people are turning
to paganism now it's quite simple really
I mean you've only gone oh look at the
government's throughout the world and
the greed that man is going against
nature and so it's not surprising the
throughout the world a lot of a lot of
people are turning back to things of
words and they're turning back to the
nature based religions of old time the
traditional religions have failed and
what people are doing now is looking
back to a time when it did work when we
were in gym the nature as opposed to a
time when we were so greedy we were out
to destroy nature so increasing numbers
of pagans but do you think people take
you seriously do you think people
respect your religion do you think
people are intimidated hated do you
think they perhaps mock it or don't take
it seriously I think people do take us
seriously I think since 1986 we've been
a multicultural nation and the British
government do take us seriously
unfortunately I don't think people like
Sky News take us seriously because you
know it's all a big joke to you and a
lot of the media fears we're a
nature-based religion we believe in the
divine we worship the divine through
nature we do not worship nature what we
worship is the divine that we see
through nature because all around us we
see the sacred what what for you was the
trigger well for me they drink it was
quite simple I realized that I was
always a pagan and you know what pagan
means it means dweller just like heathen
means of the heathland
it's the Christian connotations on the
word that have demonized this and what
about the appeal for women because it's
seen as more feminist I suppose than
traditional religions no I mean and and
that's where you're wrong again I mean
the reality is within paganism it's the
duality of the male and the female we
celebrate the Sun we celebrate
the moon the male and the female in all
things
it's duality unlike the patriarchal
religions but it's not necessarily
feminist either it's a celebration of
the duality of the male and the female
the Sun and the moon the day and the
night everything is equal and so it's
equality which is why when we meet we
meet in circles we have no egg we have
no one who sits in a pulpit we meet in
two because because circular and cycler
okay Arthur it's a Pendragon thank you
very much indeed for talking to us this
evening